[Music]
jake's in canada hi jake how are you
hey dave uh pleasure to talk to you i
never thought i'd be able to actually
communicate with you but it's a blessing
well we're honored how can we help you
um so a little bit of a back story um i
got married at a pretty young age
so
you know life is good you know we're
doing the applied baby steps we managed
to pay off a lot of debt and then
got a three to six months of an
emergency fund sitting
and um so a year and a half ago we were
blocked as a little baby boy
and um so now um you know our merrick
started getting really uh rocky is like
a
heart we had a hard time
and so um
now my wife uh she's saying how like she
doesn't want to be together anymore she
doesn't love me anymore um
she's talking to somebody else um like
in the middle of the night i'll hear her
on the phone with another person
and i just don't know what to do with
that and she wants to basically like
live at home still like in the same
house and but she could raise our son
but it's like it's a very like it's a
very difficult place for me to be in so
i just need some advice on that
i'm sorry
how old are you
uh 24.
dude you don't deserve this
no it's uh i mean it's
i mean it takes two to break a
relationship right i'm not blaming her
on at all 100 but it's
like i i wanted to make things work we
were watching a marriage counselor and
everything
and for a while there i thought things
were going good and then
about three weeks ago she said she was
done like she was completely done and
then like a couple days later she was
talking to somebody else already so it's
a
tough situation
and how old is the baby
uh he's a year and a half year and a
half oh jake i'm so sorry
yeah i mean what do you do
well
yeah i mean
in this case i mean if she's like
i mean in a sense having an emotional
affair and she's
you know talking to people and all that
i'm like she's breaking her vows
um
that she made with you
and
choosing not to
walk down a path that you guys can have
healing and move past this and so
so sure no one's perfect in a marriage
um but she's making these decisions
consciously to to go against everything
that you guys had in your marriage and
so
yeah i mean what they've said earlier
but i'm like
at that point like she doesn't she
doesn't get a lot of votes right now in
your life in my opinion
yeah
so yeah like okay
let me let me back up and just address
your initial question okay
um
if you guys can work this out and be
married
and with a marriage counselor walk
through this this patch
and she can set the phone down and
devote her life to you you can set
your issues down and devote your life to
her
that's great and i hope that's what can
happen
if the if she actually get wants a
divorce you can't stop her it's her you
can't make other people do
things okay i can't make my wife do
anything believe me
we've been married 40 years i can't make
her do anything
exactly and she really can't make me do
anything either in all fairness okay we
all make decisions as individual adults
okay
so you can't you can't make people do
what you want to do but what you can
decide is what's right for you
based on the decisions they're making
and um and you know when you say out
loud
we're gonna get a divorce and live in
the same house
and be roommates that that's just
strange weird and dumb you know when you
say that out loud that it is all of
those things right
yeah yeah exactly like it's like
it's heartbreaking not even not even a
possibility okay if we're going to go
through a divorce that means we're not
going to be married and we're going to
have separate lives
no we're not living in the same house
that's asinine
right so she doesn't want to leave jake
is that like she said she wants to stay
in the house she wants to be in the
house with you or she just wants the
house
no she wants to because she doesn't have
a degree in anything
and for her to right now like the way
the market is right now for even renting
a home would be super hard for her so
she basically wants to just live there
and like so like she does not want to go
back to work so that's because she wants
to raise our son
which like it would be better for him i
agree no it wouldn't no no it wouldn't
he does not need to be raised by
divorced parents living in the same
house together that's so freaking weird
is psychologically damaging to your son
no
yeah
no that's not better for your son
it sounds this poor girl she's so
screwed up
i don't want to work
[Laughter]
and earn money but i don't want to be
married well darling you can't you get
to choose one of the other that's not
the way this is going to work out
so
yeah i i think if we're going to get a
divorce that she's going to have to go
get an apartment you guys are going to
sell the house and you're going to go
get an apartment
okay
no you're not gonna live together all
right
i mean yeah does that mean i mean you
knew that right
yeah i did i just i just like i didn't
want to be the guy to just like decide
something you know and sports to not
work out in the end that's why well if
if you guys staying in the same house
involves healing your marriage i'm all
for it
yeah but not work out in the there is
nothing where you divorce and live in
the same house together
that works out in the end
you're a highly unattractive single guy
at this point
that you live in a house with your ex
because it says it has a big arrow above
your head that says stupid
okay
no really that would not you wouldn't
you don't want to do this you don't want
to do this no i know you don't no
but oh no no no no
and and he seems like such a kind
person
so to have the conversation with her
jake is that she's doing this like
that's my thing you're not the one
putting her out on the street and not
letting her be home with her child she's
making decisions about her life that is
now choosing to isolate herself
because she's chosen to go against her
vows to her husband so like
yeah and yeah and you're probably not
perfect i'm not saying that but like
man
it is you reap what you sow and there's
a level of consequences that she has to
face because she's making big girl
decisions and now she's about to get
some big girl results and she's got to
deal with that like that that's it's
unfair to you to be the brunt of all of
it and she calls me mean
that was very kind
i was very kind
but man it's just unfair to you jake
like i feel for you where i'm like you
don't because you're a kind person even
the way you're asking the question
you're so nice no i'm not sure we're
pretty sure we're pretty sure you're not
perfect but you are a nice guy and you
don't deserve this so no we're going to
set up a normal process that says you
have a future
away from her if she doesn't want to be
with you she is a future away from you
because she doesn't want to be with you
we can't and then you can move on with
your life and she can move on with her
life and we've got this connection with
this one and a half year old and this is
all the caveat that for some reason if
there's an issue
that she's running from the marriage to
all these other relationships that you
guys in counseling and therapy can work
through and build a stronger marriage
that's our number one right number one
is that you guys can heal this over time
um but divorced and living in the same
house is not on the agenda yes okay it's
not in the sense not on the agenda we're
just taking that off the table just not
let's just be real clear if we hadn't
already been
the way you can look at some of these
things sometimes when you're in a fog on
the decision making folks whether it's
something deeply relational like that
where your brain just shuts down because
the stress level's so high
and you really can't see clear
the way you can the way you can get
clarity when you're overwhelmed with
that kind of stuff is just projected out
ten years
okay ten years after moving in with your
ex
and living in the same house how's that
working out for you yeah
and he probably knows that but following
through
with that decision means
confrontation with her
making her move or he's moving and like
you know i'm saying like following
through with the repercussions of that
decision is messy and so entering into
that probably sounds exhausting for you
jake his decision those hers
i mean
yeah yes yes that's what we're fighting
but his decision about living in the
house with her was search of horse which
is the right decision inside the genius
yeah doesn't take 30 seconds to make
that one not
three seconds
sorry you're going through this young
man i hope it works out doesn't sound
like it's going to